the governments say that they've got
capacity to do 750
000 tests a day and so far caught during
the course of december only half of that
capacity
has been used obviously that is a total
waste and we should be using all the
capacity that we have to do the testing
especially
with the the the latest figures on the
the rise in
infections and there's nowhere where
that capacity is needed more at the
moment than intent
we've got to get that border reopened
there are other countries in the world
like norway and greece who require tests
before you can enter
the country if that's what it takes that
is what we need to do
we've had a wasted 24 hours or so where
we could have started getting that
capacity
down to kent and get those tested tests
started there's no time
to waste of ensuring our supermarket
shelves
are stacked beyond christmas and into
the new year to keep our manufacturing
industry going
but also to get great british goods to
market
in the european union we've got to get
that border open
and certainly everyone would understand
that the immediate priority is as you
say keeping those supply routes open
particularly
at this time of year at the same time
isn't there a risk
that if the british government
unilaterally offers testing on people
leaving the united kingdom through
through the ferries getting across to
europe
that will be trapped in doing that in
perpetuity 40 countries um also have now
banned travel
from the united kingdom one of the
things that we've been
slow at during the course of this
pandemic is to
uh to secure our border whether that was
to china
back in february or later to
italy where cases when faces were
rampant there we do need to secure
our border and ensure that people are
tested when they come in
to this country and quarantined properly
in a way that just hasn't happened
uh so far and and i understand the
concerns of
other countries given uh what the
government has said about
this new uh strain of the the virus
there is an urgent situation now
concerns for the welfare of those lorry
drivers
hundreds of them down in kent but also
for the british economy because we want
our great british goods to get to market
and so
this is going to be part of a
negotiation uh with with france
but we need to make sure that that
capacity is down there in kent
because if it is tests that are needed
to get that border open and we have that
testing capacity
here in the uk you know let's just get
it sorted
and get that capacity down there so that
border can reopen as quickly as possible
because these
delays are costing british businesses
and
if they're not sorted soon will result
in shortages both for manufacturing and
potentially in our supermarkets with
prices rising as well
and given that the challenges that
family finances are under at the moment
we really don't need that on top of
everything else
indeed um in terms of what we learned
from the government yesterday you'll be
aware of the remarks
uh from the government's chief
scientific advisor sir patrick valance
that
there is a likelihood that measures
those coronavirus restrictions
will be needed in some places in due
course in his words as the as the
variant spreads
is it the labour party's position that
we should be seeing a move to tier four
rather more quickly than the government
is intimating
it's labor's position that we should
follow the science on all of this
and we're urging government to publish
the scientific advice when it comes in
not with a lag
what we saw back in the autumn was that
sage made recommendations on the 21st of
september
for a circuit break the government
didn't publish the minutes of that sage
meeting
until the 10th of october they were
three wasted weeks where
the public didn't know the scale of the
challenge we faced all the scientific
advice
let's not have that lag there has been
you know
a general tendency over the last few
months for
the prime minister and the government to
reject the uh evidence
then to uh to ridicule anyone that
questions government strategy
and then deny that any changes that are
needed and then
with a a a great lag introducing the
measures that are necessary
but by that stuff just to be just be
absolutely clear right
to be absolutely clear are you accusing
the government of concealing
information from the public of covering
up the true extent of
the spread of covert 19. no on september
the 21st
the sage met and they recommended a
circuit break
the minutes of that meeting was not
published until the 10th of october
i believe that the government should be
publishing that information from the
scientists much quicker so the public
can understand
that and understand the decisions that
government are making
but i also urge the government to act
much quicker
when that information is presented to
them and what we've seen during the
course of this crisis is
dithering delay at every stage and
as a result the measures that are needed
whether
it was the circuit break that was needed
back in september october but didn't
come in until
november or whether it was tougher
measures which you know no one wanted to
see
but are necessary around christmas those
changes not coming in until
at the weekend which then caused
pandemonium
on the trains at the weekend you know
the government need to act when the
scientists say
and uh you know every delay means
that there is more pressure on the nhs
and and
more people becoming infected with this
virus so what i'm saying is the
government has got to stop this general
pattern of diver and delay
to act on the science and the decisions
are not always going to be popular
but that's what comes with power and
responsibility
sometimes you've got to take tough
decisions that are in the national
interest
and labor will always do that and that
is why we have supported this government
in terms of the restrictions that are
necessary to control this virus
even though we know that it is causing
hardship for many
many people and that's why we're also
saying government need to do more
in terms of supporting businesses and
supporting families